we have a voicemail number which is 2192
david p
uh we have heard a number of times
recently from this furious trumpist who
calls in jimmy from philly
the eggman a longtime caller and viewer
and listener who we love
we love the eggman he called in and he
is now going directly at jimmy from
philly take a listen to this
hey dave this is a message for your
employee uh jimmy from philly
that's a joke by the way jimmy is just a
caller i wanted to tell him
why we take our children to blm rallies
we take them because we don't want our
children to grow up to be
racist homophobic [ __ ]
like you right shalom a huge shalom
a huge huge shot across the bow there
from the eggman against jimmy from
philly
um and we will see if i get 10
voicemails from jimmy
responding to the eggman four of which
will have a bad reception
six of which will be way too loud to use
we'll see if that happens uh when i wake
up tomorrow morning
on the bonus show today we are in the
last week
almost in the last week last full week i
guess maybe we could say
of that enhanced 600 unemployment
benefit related to coronavirus
that's going to have a big impact when
it ends and we're going to talk about it
on today's bonus show
we also were seeing police use drones
even to monitor nudity at a minnesota
beach
and i want to talk about that and
there's the context of
facial recognition technology and other
things that are relevant
and number three uh not the best health
news
for supreme court justice ruth bader
ginsburg we're going to talk about
what's going on
this is putting a renewed focus on the
supreme court
and what may or may not uh be
supreme court picks that that trump
would have in the remainder
of this term or in a possible second
term and how mitch mcconnell might try
to obstruct and and
we're going to see how it all plays out
but we will have a
serious discussion about it on the bonus
show today make sure you get access to
the bonus show by becoming a member
at joinpackman.com also something extra
tonight 9 p.m eastern
i will be doing a live stream on twitch
with international chess master eric
rosen a friend of the show
my continued training for a big upcoming
tournament where i am looking to
represent the progressive political
community very powerfully in a chess
tournament
um i am taking i actually i'm taking it
seriously join my training tonight on
twitch at 9 pm eastern
twitch.tv david pakman
it's all happening and remember if you
prefer
a one hour long form audio podcast
each day rather than little cut up clips
on youtube
you can get our daily audio podcast for
free
on any of your favorite podcasting
platforms a lot of people use itunes
many people prefer spotify we're on
pandora
google play stitcher all of the
pod bean uh what else spreaker i don't
even know all the platforms we're on
but you can consume the show daily in
that way and as people
hopefully in like nine months get back
to safely commuting to work
um you'll be able to take a show with
you in that format remember the audio
podcast available daily
i will speak to you in mere moments on
today's bonus show